BEGIN TO BEHAVE IN A CIVILIZED
MANNER.
THAT'S JUST THE AGE WE LIVE IN
I'M AFRAID.
BETWEEN CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICANS IN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OVER ACCESS TO
INFORMATION ABOUT A LARGE
INFILTRATION OF THE TRUMP
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
KATHERINE HARRIS IS HERE WITH AN
UPDATE AND IT SEEMS LIKE WE ARE
GOING INTO THESE ALL THE TIME.
>> THE FBI DIRECTOR AND DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ARE NOW
SCHEDULED TO TESTIFY PUBLICLY ON
THURSDAY AS A PITCHED BATTLE FOR
REPUBLICANS IS THAT THE OFFICIAL
JULY 2016 TIMELINE CONFLICTS
WITH RECORDS THAT SUGGEST THE
FBI BEGAN GATHERING INTELLIGENCE
MUCH EARLIER THAN PUBLICLY
THAT WE HAVE BEEN AFTER FOR A
VERY LONG TIME, AND THAT IS, IS
AGENCIES OR CAPABILITIES OF THIS
OFFICIALLY OPENED THE RUSSIA
CASE ON JULY 31, 2016.
THE RECORDS FOCUS ON
INTELLIGENCE ACTIVITIES AND AT
THE FBI USE CONFIDENTIAL HUMAN
SOURCES TO INVESTIGATE TRUMP
CONGRESS THAT THE FBI BELIEVES
REQUEST, AND THAT THE FBI USE,
DON'T LIKE IT SOURCES PRIOR TO
THAT INVESTIGATION.
THOUGHT DIRECTOR DID NOT PROVIDE
A CONFERENCE OF RESPONSE AND THE
DEPARTMENT WRONGLY LIMITS THE
EFFORTS TO CONGRESSIONAL
LEADERSHIP.
TWITTER.
I'VE TRIED TO STAY UNINVOLVED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND THE FBI, ALTHOUGH I DON'T
LEGALLY HAVE TO.
BUT I HAVE TO ASK WHAT THEY ARE
STATEMENT, REPUBLICANS WANT THE
RECORD TO HELP PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND IT TO UNDERMINE THE